thanks gary thanks for the introduction
um yeah let me start by
giving a quick introduction of myself
i'm adjosens i'm a freelance
sports data engineer i have a background
in human movement sciences so
yeah exercise physiology after my
studies
i went to work as a first as a web
developer later as a data engineer
and at the moment i'm combining my my
background in exercise physiology with
with data engineering as a sports data
engineer
um i'm explicitly not calling myself a
data scientist
what i'm doing is i'm helping
organizations companies that have
like sports data engineering tasks
with these tasks and also give them some
domain knowledge uh from the world of
specifically
endurance sports like uh cycling
um triathlon rowing running
sports like sports like that and yeah so
talking about these sports my the
these parts that have my expertise i um
i looked at the the people that
registered for this uh
meetup and i i think that most of most
of you have or at least a big big
chunk of the the attendees of this uh
this meetup
as you see this picture as the the
pinnacle of sports for
performance and i'm afraid to say that
that my talk will be more
more about this okay maybe not not this
guy this uh
middle-aged man and like rabbit more
like this
but i'm hoping that uh even the the
diehard soccer fans
that are here in this virtual meet meet
up i'll i can show them
in this presentation that in cycling
there's also very interesting data and
some very interesting uh
data challenges to to solve with that
let's get started with my talk so the
title of my talk was exploration of a
public gate set of endurance activities
uh actually a more um specific accurate
uh title would be exploration of golden
cheetah open data
a public data set with a lot of bike
rides because that that what it said
that's what it
basically comes comes down to um i cut
my
talk in uh in three parts i'll start
with a quick introduction to
cycling data um so for people that are
not too familiar with
data lens data analysis in
in endurance sports and cycling in
general this will help us
like introduction uh a quick
introduction and for those that
that are familiar it will uh who might
act as a refresher
after that i will go to uh the the
actual explanation exploration of the
golden cheetah open data set
and i'll finish off with um
yeah with a small data sciency project
i'm
i'm doing with these with this data to
to give an example of what
uh what challenges you can can solve
using a
a public data set like this computer or
the data sets
uh yeah so let's get started with this
introduced cycling data
data collection in cycling is um
yes mainly it's the the main bit almost
all of the data that's collected in
cycling is
collected during training rides or
or races so cyclists
have a bike computer on their bike and
they were a heart rate monitor
they maybe even have a power meter on
their bike
speed sensor cadence sensor maybe they
even collect some cycling
like some pedaling technique uh
temperature
and and this data is uh yeah so this is
an example list of this
this data this data is typically you
collected
on by computer sampled at one hertz uh
some by computers try to do it
differently which is a hassle for people
like me to
standardize that and then after a ride
a training or a raise these these data
are saved in
in my computer as a for example fit file
or sync to any of the
the training platforms that are
available um
so quick uh introduction to
to some of the training platforms that
are available for for endurance sports
um the top row those those are the three
i'd say the three biggest biggest one as
strava is um
not so much targeting data analysis
well it is also but they also have a big
big social component
and today's plan and training peaks are
targeting competitive athletes endurance
athletes
and also specifically those who have a
coach who are working with
with the coach do with the train um yeah
the bottom ones
are three ones that i wanted to give a
quick shout out because i find them uh
very interesting the first one is
interval infiltrated isu which is a
relatively new one um but i really like
the
the simplicity but also the the the
number of features that this
this platform has they i think they
will be a big competitor for the big
three
laptop in the coming years and golden
cheetah is an open source desktop
application so it's the only one in this
list that's not a
a platform in the cloud it's it has a
desktop application
it's a completely developed completely
open source
and the data that we're going to look at
today
as the name might suggest is is coming
from this application and i'll talk
about that
in a bit and the last one that i wanted
to give a shout-out to is
human go it's a us-based startup that i
uh
that i work with and they're developing
a um
a training platform for endurance and
athletes that provides
adaptive training plans for these these
athletes it's a really exciting
platform to work with um so golden
cheetah golden cheetah open data
and so as i just said this this golden
cheat
desktop application is open source can
be downloaded by everyone used by
everyone
and i think it was in 2016 and somewhere
in 2016.
um the the developers of this
application implemented a feature that
asked the users
if they were willing to share their data
their
data from their rights or their runs or
their swims
in a public data set in the golden g to
open data sets and
a lot of people did that over the past
years
and yeah so this data is shared by users
with their consent
the data is anonymized yeah i think so
the names and
birthdays gps
data is stripped from the from the data
and then updated to
aws s3 bucket to
made available for for everyone and at
the moment i've
last checked that last week there are
over 6 000 athletes in this
in this data set with well over half a
terabyte of data
and uh over two and a half million uh
activities which can be rides uh run
swims or any any kind of data that is in
uh
that is a stored in in golden cheetah
that will start in
in golden cheetah um
yeah so to give a quick overview of what
the data looks like in this
in this open data set i'll make this a
bit
bigger for you to see uh so for every
athlete there's a there's a big json
file that contains
uh some generic information about uh
yeah so if you look at the top it shows
a year of birth
in this case someone entered that wrong
and gender and an athlete id and then
for every right that this athlete has
has stored in golden cheetah is
there are some additional metadata like
sports which data is available to date
of course but
a lot more metrics like like that
and then next to this json with metadata
of the of the athlete
all the the separate uh activities
separate rights are uh are stored as a
are available as a as a csv file with uh
like this so there there's a second
column that
of course contains the time step and
then other columns with the
with the available data for each each
activity
um yeah with that it's time it's demo
time
i get back i'll switch to my
laptop yeah um
i deployed um
an application to explore this data here
i'll leave this url open for you to
to copy it if you if you want but i'll
join it
after the presentation as well um
it's a data set
application and a dataset is is a
framework that is basically
a front-end on top f on top of a
an sqlite a sqlite database
and i think it's really cool technology
to
to make data like this available and
browsable
and uh yeah the ease of which you can
then
deploy something uh like this and make
it available for everyone
i think it's really interesting so if
you're uh if you haven't heard about
dataset before please go and go check it
out and
build a uh try to build some
applications with that
as well um
yeah so um if you go to this url it
shows you some
explanations about the data that's in
the
in the database uh the main thing is
here at the bottom there are two tables
in this
uh in this data set this data explorer
that i um
um that i developed there's the
athletes table that we'll take a look at
first um
yeah so if you scroll down you'll see
basically a table structure with
uh a number of columns and at least a
gender
uh year of birth so the the actual the
the
precise birth date is uh pseudonymized
um
um but the year of birth which is very
useful information to do some analysis
is
still maintained so it's nice to have
that in the data and then there's a url
to the to the metadata this
is json file and a url to the
uh to the zip file with all the seeds
fees
that i just showed um
yeah so um yeah so this is one of the
tables and then
in data set you can actually write sql
queries
um to explore this data so
let's start with a very simple one so uh
the one
that we that we have now that's shown
here results in detail below so that
basically shows all the comments from
this data set
limits orders them by row id
and limits to a number of
101 lines but let's say that we want to
explore
um how many uh uh
yeah how many athletes there are for
each each gender then we can do
something like
this this is just uh yeah don't be
full don't be scared by uh by what i'm
doing now it's just
showing that you can write a raw sql um
queries in this data set application and
uh let me check so order by
which i'll be going to order by by two
and then we're going to yeah this should
do it so we have a total
gender count of 280 females and uh
well over 6 000 um uh
males in this so this is just a quick
example of what you can
and how you can explore these these data
and then let's go to the other table in
this uh
in this data explorer which is the the
right one which i think is actually the
more
more interesting uh one yeah so we'll
start with a quick
quick overview of the data so you can
see some some columns here
there's a date column which is the of
course the the date of the
the write that up in the sport and
the the data and the data column
contains the um a letter for each
data type that is um
that is a that is available and i at the
home page of the data explorer
i uh provided a list with the
translations for these for these letters
so
for example b stands for power so if you
go back to
here and then look for a write that has
power
okay the first ones don't don't have
that we can try to to look for
for that so if you go here and select
the column
data and find the ones that contain the
letter
b then we'll find
of course the ones that and
then we'll find all the rights that that
have power
okay um yeah let me think i on the
on the home page uh i added some some
example queries that you can uh
can start with so i think there are some
interesting ones there but you can also
use these uh
these queries for example um
um let me check which is an interesting
one
yeah so the right counter athletes there
might be an interesting one
so this will describe we'll count the
number of rights for for each athletes
and sort them by
by this so the the top one with this
athlete id
has a count of uh well a bit over 10
000 rights which is really is a lot and
but there yeah there are a lot with
multiple thousands of variety nodes so
i think this is a very interesting um
uh it is a very interesting and and big
data set to
to work with um one thing to note
is that it is crowdsourced data so
uh the data is not cleaned or
[Music]
the data is not checked or cleaned
before or after it is uploaded so that
is something you have to
you have to work with and one way to
look at that is if we are going to
if you are looking at the the sport
types
so the sport column let me check from
right group by
one order by two yeah i think this
should work
yeah so this is the the sport column and
then showing the
each each occurrence of each value
and then sorted by these values so there
are a lot of bike rides uh
one point almost 1.8 million if i'm
correct
yeah also a lot of runs and a lot of
swims if you scroll down
um it also contains sports like
road which probably means road cycling
and then if you go further down and
there's also there's some uh
which i think is a german sport type
cycle uh cyclismo
so there's some yes there's some noise
in the data definitely so
again it's it's crowdsourced data so you
have to be aware of that and and take
that into account when
when you're doing analysis on on this um
yeah so one final example query that i
wanted to show before i go to the uh
to show what we can actually do with
this uh with this data
um this create a more yeah more
complex query and with a nested query in
there
it shows the for each athlete the right
count the right count with power so the
number of rights that that have power
data and then the percentage of total
uh yeah the percentage of total rights
that have
half power and why i did this is because
i want to do
some analysis on power data and for this
i want to have a
have an athlete with a the highest
or at least a high percentage of our
data in their
activities and i think in the end i
ended up with this athlete because i
think all
these ones are were uploaded later they
were uploaded after i started uh
started this project so the data that
you you'll be seeing
after this and some analyses is coming
from this
this athlete study which has a almost 97
power availability in his or her right i
don't actually know the gender of this
this athlete um
with that let's go back to the uh
presentation so why are we
how can we use this and data why is it
interesting to
to have this this data and i think i
mentioned this um
starts when i talk so all this data that
we collect uh
from for example cyclists but i think
the same applies to
to any endurance um
endurance athlete or any endurance sport
is that we're
monitoring trying to monitor fitness and
fitness is a bit of a
yeah well i'm not sure i wouldn't say
that it is not well defined with
but i think there are a lot of
definitions and i'm keeping it
explicitly
fake for this for the sake of this talk
but what i sort of mean that is
fitness is sort of is equal to to
performance but it also includes
includes fatigue so it's more of a
container
term to use uh to use here um so with
this data that we just saw we
we can use it to to to monitor fitness
um
why is fitness so important and yeah as
a disclaimer this is
the chart that i created here is not
based on any data not any science it's
incredible social simplification but i
think it helps to
to understand for people that are not
necessarily familiar with cycling
why um why fitness is so uh so important
so let's have the example of football of
course fitness is important as well the
the
the soccer players the football players
they need to have a certain fitness too
to run across these uh
these fields but tactics are are also
very important as we
saw on the in the previous uh stock for
cycling that's
that's uh that's less less the case
tactics are
um for some uh types of bike races
those are uh tactics are important but
fitness is is by far the the most
important thing
and especially if you look at um yeah so
again this is not based on any any
scientific data but
i think for a one day road races tactics
play
play a big play a big part so for
example
flanders spell just just happened
and tactics played a big role there but
for multi-stage
races like the tour de france or or
especially time trials or cyclocross
racing
fitness is basically all that matters
it's tactics don't
play a play a big role there anymore so
that's why measuring fitness
is important but measuring fitness is
also hard
i think the the reasons for this are can
be boiled down to
two reasons one of those is that test
selection is
is hard it's hard to to determine which
test is
gives the results you you want for uh
for your athlete for the type of race
you're training uh
for so let's say that you put an athlete
on a
in the laboratory laboratory environment
on a
on a bike and put my the sphere to max
these vo2 sensors on his mouth and then
measure his vo2 max using a specific
protocol but then
what does that tell you about um how we
will perform on a
20 kilometer or 100 kilometer time trial
or
how what will that tell you about what
how you will perform in
the rain in the cold so test selection
is a big
big factor that makes monitoring fitness
hard but also that doing any
um maximal tests to measure
fitness or performance or whatever you
want to call it um
it induces fatigue and its uh
effects and sometimes even screws up
your training schedule that that
for this athlete and this this second
bit
is uh what i'm trying to uh uh
solve or did it yeah so the the the
small data science product that i
mentioned in the in the beginning this
basically tries to tackle this uh
the second factor there are multiple
ways to to look at this
at this problem one of the ways to
measure
fitness without inducing fatigue is for
example
looking at resting heart rate of an
athlete or heart rate viability
but there are many more um ways to do
that and one of those is
looking at mean maximal power curves mmp
curves the
term i uh i think i'm interested at the
start of my talk
so what are these these mmp curves um
they're defined as and i think i really
realize that this might be a difficult
sentence to uh
to understand so for every possible
duration t the maximum mean power
where t is less or equal than the total
duration of the activity
so it basically means that for every
duration within an activity
you take the best best power the best uh
yeah the best power and value
yeah to clarify that a bit more um let's
look at this uh
this workout that i created it's a very
uh
not so complex uh workout it starts with
a warming up of two minutes at um uh
at 100 watts and then it uh does three
uh high intensity intervals at 300 watts
uh with uh one minute rest in between
and then it ends with two
two minutes uh at 100 watts
as you could let's put it like that so
then how looks the
does the mean maximal power for this
uh workout look like it looks like
this so the the plot on the right
so if we look at the look at it so the
x-axis
on the on the left plot of the workout
it's it's time and on the
right one it's duration so it's slightly
different
basically says that if you look at here
at
one minute um
300 watt tells you that during this
workout
the athlete had a maximum one minute
average power of 300 watts
and if you look here at two minutes
means that during this workout
the athlete had a maximum two minute
average power
of 200 watts and so forth so for
three minutes it's about uh i'd say 2 33
something like that
and for uh five minutes it's
just a bit over over 200 watts
i hope this explains that the concept of
uh
of this min max power a bit you helps
understand
the rest of this this presentation um
yeah so this is uh of course uh uh all
right so maybe just a quick question
that kind of came through just to make
sure we're on the same page
sure um in the the data set that you get
and if
you if i understood correctly you rely
on knowing the training schedule right
so you in that graph on the left
you have uh you know that there's red
low power and then you have an intense
peak and then low
does that is that data captured in the
golden cheetah framework that you know
what people are supposed to be doing or
do you only see what's on the right hand
side and then you have to deduce oh this
was a specific training schedule that
someone was using
yesterday i think my next slide will
will explain that so the
the work i did just show you what showed
you was a like a theoretical
workout it could be could be part of a
training plan but the data that uh that
we actually
use to calculate calculate these mean
maximal power curves
is the actual data from a a a bike ride
so
for this due to work the athlete needs
to have a power meter then if this power
is recorded during a
uh workout uh data like this will
will be recorded and this data is can
then be used to calculate a mean by x
power curve for this
right so the this
this what i showed here is is a
theoretical example to explain the
concept of
uh mean max power and the actual data
that we use for our analysis is built on
these these actual bike rides does that
explain the question
yeah very good very good thank you okay
sure no problem
okay so uh yeah so this is how data from
power data from an actual bike rides
looks like so it's a bit more uh well a
bit more fluctuating than my theoretical
example um and the mean max power curve
for
uh for a ride like this looks it looks a
bit like this which
you could say is a bit less interesting
in this case one way to to get a bit
more knowledge out of me max poker from
a single single workout is to
not use a linear x-axis but a log
log scale so then it's a bit more easy
to both see
detail in at shorter durations but also
at
longer durations so i think in this case
let me make it a bit bigger
in this case it's um well let's say
that it's quite good to see that at the
sort of 10 minute mark i'd say and
there's a
big drop of in in data which i suspect
corresponds to uh to this interval
and then yeah there's well
the log scale helps to to get get a bit
more detail uh
compared to if you just use these this
linear axis and i will use this lost
skill and
try the rest of the dock which is
not a lot of time remaining so i'll
speed up a bit
um yeah so how can we use this mmp for
for monitoring fitness and one way to do
that is
is just record mmp values
for a number of uh
itself in a view again to to record
these mmp values for a number of
durations so in this uh
study they did that for 5 10 30
seconds 1 5 10 20 16 120 180 minutes
and then track those uh mmps so these
these best times best race and times uh
over
over time um and so this is a very
typical uh
way how that's how that's done and the
study of
peter leo does a similar thing but then
combines
training and racing data um
but there's a different way to do this
and that is using power duration
models and these models basically
what they do is get these mmp data so
the gray
gray dots in this plot and try to plot a
model uh
model over this and there are a lot of
well
quite a lot of models that that are
available for this they all
rely on in some way a form of a
on critical power and w prime balance so
there's the two parameter critical power
model there's a three parameter
parameter critical power that
there's the exponential critical power
model but the one that i was interesting
on and uh
the reason i started this small project
is the
a model that was published i think it
was last year to
see a year yeah except that february
2020
and about this by michael putchowitz and
it's called the omnipotent
power duration only domain power the
race model wow that's a mouthful
okay um so how do we apply this model
what i basically did is is grab
a big bucket of data and that's where
the golden cheetah output data set comes
in
and then calculate the mmp curves for
for each of these
these writes calculate the max value
for for each duration so that's the
that's the black dots here
and then fit the model through through
these max
maximum values um
this yields um yeah so
it this yields quite quite good results
you can see that the model
yeah sort of okay follows the
the maximum power curves um there's an
issue with
fitting your model to data like this and
that is
this disclaimer that the mmp data is
above all
a measure of what has been done and not
necessarily of performance so
if you take a big bucket of
[Music]
bike ride data this data will not only
contain
maximal efforts it will also contain all
the rides where
the cyclist the athlete will uh just out
with the friends to uh
um uh to drink some uh to drink some
coffee
um but there will also be so some
maximum effort for someone's printed to
the next village or uh did the maximal
efforts
up a mountain and it's hard to um
see it's yeah so it's it's actually not
hard to see but it's hard to
filter out the submaximal bits of this
this data and that
that is the the the challenge that i was
trying to to solve here
so if we look at uh so this is showing
it says four but i think it's three
writes and then plotting the data
and sorry fitting the model fitting the
model
to it and then you see that for
especially for these
shorter durations we get a bit bigger
especially for these shorter durations
the model
underestimates the what this athlete can
actually
do for some durations besides you could
say it overestimates
or maybe for these durations the athlete
hasn't done any
any maximal maximal effort so the model
fit is a bit of a problem
here it's less so a problem if you have
a lot of data so this is
all the data from this athlete that we
just saw in the in the golden cheetah
open data explorer um but still there's
some bits where
the model is for example here
and here where the model is
underestimating the
the the capability the fitness of the
of this athlete and um
it's very very uh easy to see this if
you plot the residuals of in this case
the
in first residual so this shows
um how many watts the uh
model you have this right how many
what's the model is below
uh sorry above the um
uh above the actual data the training uh
training data
and yeah notice this makes sense but
what i'm basically trying to do is i
want to minimize the area
under the curve here i don't want the
model to be
under the curve anywhere because this
will
mean that the model is fitted to to
submaximal data
um yeah so one approach that i tried
here and
if you have any ideas about this please
reach reach out to me and
venture ideas because i would really
like some input here so
basically what i'm trying to do is do an
envelope fit on these
on this mmp
curve and one way i i try to do that is
doing an initial model fit then getting
rid of all the
training data that falls below the the
fitted model then do another fit and
repeat the process
in this case after five runs it's a bit
hard to see in the plot here
if we look at the residual plot again
you can see that actually the area under
the curve
is well maybe here there's one bit more
and the area in the curve is is is
minimized so the
um the fitted model is actually fitted
quite well to what i think are the
the maximal efforts um
and again one thing phil to mention so
the in the the
red dashed line here is the the
model fat that we saw earlier so it's
this initial prediction
the black one is the the final
prediction that was
fitted after after these five runs
um yeah so again to to close my
talk off again i'm repeating this this
disclaimer that
although the model fit that you that you
saw and that i come up with
might look good or might even be good
statistically
it's still a measure of what has been
done and not necessarily of performance
so it's always
good to keep that in mind when using bar
duration models like uh
like this um with that i want to close
off my talk i think i'm a bit over
half an hour already i want to finish
off with the open source
shout out to some of some open source
products that have made this
this talk
[Music]
possible so first off of course golden
cheetah the the desktop
application to to analyze your your bike
rights then the golden gita
open data project and a projector that
i'm a corman danerov
is sweatpay which is python library to
do the analysis and all the analyses
that
all the plots that you just shown are
done using this
this library um so if you have any
questions or interested in working with
me or if you have
any ideas on how i can continue to
improve on this
inspiration model fitting please reach
out to me or
i think there's still a bit of time left
to
answer some questions here in this
virtual meetup thanks
thank you guys this is very cool very
inspiring so um i i
i know a lot of people are very
impressed with where you're switching
with your video behavior and drawing so
the presentation awesome thank you for
that
nice maybe a bit more on uh more on some
of the technicalities there are quite a
few questions that came through that
some came directly to me some are more
public
one of them was the athlete data that
you showed was very biased
towards men versus women do you know if
there's an initiative to change that
and in general uh more importantly how
how important is that in your particular
sphere of
work so uh any thoughts on that yeah
yeah yeah it's it's a very very good
point very very good question i think
this
well i'm not conducting any uh science
but i think in
science in this in this field in the
field of exercise
there's a there's a problem with a lack
of
of female data to put it put it like
that and
this data set is only an example of of
that
yeah so to be honest there is no effort
at the moment
to to get more female data into this
platform because
we don't have any control of which users
are downloading
the golden data application coding
cheater application and then deciding to
actually share their data
in this in this data set so uh
i think there's yeah so if you have any
ideas on that
let me know but i think that's i don't
know how we can
can improve on that um but it is an
issue i think the
so the model that i just showed is very
uh very personal i think
there's no um there's no generalization
uh that that could be a different for
for males and and females i think if you
would apply
a model like this to a
broader group so we're trying to fit a
perturbation model like that over
uh data from from multiple athletes then
yeah i think the lack of uh of data from
a few athletes is definitely
an issue an issue you should take that
into account when
applying these models yeah right very
good so so that that balance is that so
there was another
a few other few interesting questions
that came through is one of it is uh
in your experience how much of what
happened before the date is being
collected matters
so so the idea is i think most
professionals when they train
especially seriously they have a
training schedule and
depending on when the last time they did
sport and how many hours ago that may or
may not impact their performance for
the next session does that influence
your data is that something that uh
the dataset holds or is that something
you would like to hold
um what are your thoughts on that yeah
that's also a very good question yeah
that's that's yeah one of the bigger
challenges in monitoring fitness is
um incorporating the the role of the
the impact of previous activities on
on uh the metrics of today
so in this case um
yeah i'm thinking what's the application
to this
so i think in this case i'm not too
worried about that because the
um let's say that you're that you did a
really hard race yesterday and then did
it work out today
and the mmp values of your of today's
workout will just drop below the the
mmp curve and won't be included in the
in a model
but if you want to use this uh this
power iteration model to predict
performance
you certainly have to take into account
the uh
the training load from the past few days
obviously uh
yeah there are a lot of ways to do that
i think the um
the best way to to handle that is look
at the acute chronic
work ratio if i'm correct so that
basically
takes a an average training load from
the past
i think the the standard is 42 days
and then take that as a fitness
measure but then also taking the seven
day efforts um
a training load and that they take that
as a fatigue
um as a measure of fatigue
and then using those to to feed a model
and that way you could
uh you could predict uh maybe use a
powder ratio model like this to uh
uh predict performance i hope that
explains your question answers your
question yes thank you very much
and then so you don't ask the question
here is there he says there also appears
to be some correlation structure in the
residuals
do the curve fitting algorithms take
this into account
sorry i i don't understand that cause
correlation in the residuals
so um uh i i i think um so you know he's
trying to
uh he would like to see the residuals
again so if you look at the residuals
again you know
this is triggered as attention and so i
think
uh i think you think you don't you can
ask the question if you unmute yourself
just you
uh feel free to ask it personally
or maybe we muted him so so maybe we can
take his question offline then ah so uh
oh yes i'm here i think okay good so
what i observe is when you right
normally when you fit a
an ordinary linear regression model you
expect the residuals
to be independent of each other so you
expect if if once
above a certain threshold that you
expect
the the other one below now here there
is
obviously you're working with the time
series right
but you're also working probably with
some more complicated
correlations in the fact that i can
imagine if you have a peak performance
that's quite high then you may then that
may affect your mean maximal power for
a different duration so how do these
models take into account
this correlation uh
yeah i'm still not sure if i fully
understand your question but that
might be a lack of knowledge on my part
um
i think i can say that they don't take
that into account so the
this max power curve is basically an
expanding moving average so
every every point in team time is
influenced by the
by the by the points point before so
there's of course a correlation in in
that
in that sense yes does that explain your
question
uh yeah yeah well yeah i'm just
interested in the paper as well so if
you could
provide a link then i'll uh
i'm sure there's a possibility to share
some uh
some things yeah and we'll get arts to
go to the matplotlib library so when we
join meebo in a few minutes we're going
to get art to go to the matplotlib so
you can
find them in the matplotlib uh channel
all right
then maybe just one last question to rip
it up
um does this fitness uh model apply to
other sports so
so uh this you seem to do it based on
cycling but this seems a very important
aspect for many other sports does this
methodology and models
apply to other sports as well or is it
very much geared towards cycling
yeah that's a good question yeah so
that's a very relevant
question the the reason i chose cycling
is
because cycling is a it's a very lucky
sport in the sense that it's very easy
to
measure power and power is the the the
intensity or the yeah so that
that's that's already power output and
power output is a measure of the the
work that
that an athlete
[Music]
delivers over over a specific time time
period and
cycling is one of the few sports where
you can do this
as easily as uh
yeah as easily as in cycling i think
there are a few other sports where you
can do this
um i think rowing is is one there's some
efforts to do the same
in running but it's more an estimation
of of power than a real measure of power
um yeah so in that sense cycling is an
easiest part to pick for
doing power ratio modeling like this but
that being said there are so
at least some efforts to do
not power duration modeling but speed
duration modeling so basically doing the
same but then
on uh on speed speed data
to be honest i'm not completely sure
what's the the
the scientific status of these these
efforts but i think
the yeah sort of the same models the
same ideas
apply there i wouldn't say that this
only the
only domain poweration model and will
directly apply to
the speed duration it will will be
applicable as a speed duration model but
maybe some of the
underlying theory might right
very